a bird in New York City doesn't have it
easy
whether it's flying into a building a
car a bicycle dogs pollution lead poison
this is not nature's natural course we
have interfered with it my name is Rita
McMahon and I'm the co-founder and
director of the wild bird fund New York
City's one and only wildlife
rehabilitation center we take in birds
that anyone has found and we do our best
to make it whole so that it can go back
to the wild the atmosphere at the wild
bird fund is something of a three-ring
circus
there's the ISO room waterfowl room
reception area and downstairs is a whole
nother thing there are a couple of
hundred Birds down there they may be
flying around in the air as people are
scurrying around cleaning the cages
giving them meds and feeding them we
deal with 135 different species this
past week we had a Canada Goose 7
kestrels a rowdy bunch of juvenile
herring gulls this year 2016 we will
treat well over 4000 Birds by being in
New York City where the animal is found
we are able to save many more animals
they would die before they could get
help in another state or another County
people can come to you by a subway or
bus and they can get the animal to you
faster it's exciting you never really
know who's going to walk through that
door or what they're holding in that box
I was at my store and I saw the pigeon I
saw that he was like bleeding on the
floor like pretty bad I didn't even know
that they took in pigeons
any animal that is picked up is in
really bad shape 50% will die or are
euthanized if we can reduce the
suffering that's a good thing too but
50% go free when the birds better you
try to return it to where it came if
it's an adult bird it might have family
friends it knows where to live the
migratory birds they're just passing
through you're really just trying to put
them in a safe place so that they can
continue their journey